easy comics boy for a black site they're
very specific about its location
gee I wonder if any male character will
be able to own this female prisoner
character Harley steals the Juliette
Lewis from Natural Born Killers Garen
watching monitor was preoccupied with
Chinese food or Pizza cliche playing
sympathy for the devil during the
introduction of the main asshole of the
movie shows that this movie's asshole is
really the biggest asshole of the movie
bad news mr. Eyre we've blown the entire
soundtrack budget inside four minutes of
the movie take the rest of what you need
out of my salary
um fair more songs you heard me god damn
it the world changed when Superman flew
across the sky not the main character
starts narrating four minutes into the
picture the opens a restaurant named
after a recurring bug infestation was
just like naming your restaurant brood X
or even malaria carriers Superman who
shared our values this sounds like
something a person would say who hadn't
seen Man of Steel in Batman V Superman
at least if our values include not
murdering thousands of innocent
civilians no no pictures that Task Force
X project of yours again are you you
guys didn't discuss this before you set
up this meeting at the swanky restaurant
Floyd Lawton aka Deadshot we saw
Deadpool and decided it wanted some of
that sweet sweet graphic credits love
only in the process it forgot to be
funny so we're left with stylized
character introductions without soul
this will be introduced us to both
Deadshot and Harley Quinn in the first
minute but now we're getting second
introductions of them before we've even
gotten to the new characters yet seems
like this movie could have started with
Viola Davis and cut out all the creepy
guard bullsh as Deadshot great with guns
because he naturally has amazing
hand-eye coordination or is because he
has this incredible scope that lines
everything up for I just gave an
anonymous chip to the right guy in
Gotham City an anonymous tip about what
if you followed his daughter to get him
why didn't you arrest him on your own it
just seems like a spot where you wanted
to introduce Batman into the movie would
you put him let's just say put him in
the hole and throw away the hole well no
no he's in a regular ass maximum
security so that line makes it sound
like he parallax Tim first off the
murder of Robin is played like some
trifling thing that we get a blip of
text about second off this is the second
movie in the DCU this year to hint at a
Robin die story that would have been way
better than the two movies we actually
got she thought she was curing him but
she was falling in love but why because
he's so handsome or because she never
should have been certified to treat
Asylum patients in the first place due
to her own insanity and
even though she fell for him it's still
kind of hard to believe she got him a
machine gun I'm just gonna hurt you
really really badly badly Jesus it's
like playing cards with my sister's kids
Joker has his girlfriend strip dancing
in this club seemingly only to invite
fools to covet her too much or call her
a bad bitch so Joker can kill them at
the risk of sounding doubly sexist if
you're this jealous why let your lady
strip dance in the club yo Wow for a
major metropolitan city Gotham's River
has some clean ass water also Joker flat
out abandoned his woman to save his own
skin that may be in character for him
but it's still a dick move worthy of
sinning also somehow Joker managed to
crash this car into the water find a way
out of the car and swim out of the view
of Batman before Batman jumped into the
water which if you recall was right
after they crashed I don't care how
crazy you are there is no way you can
somehow crash into the water then have
the wherewithal to pull out your knife
and fake unconsciousness for future
Batman killing after being threatened by
a tiny knife from a woman that's trapped
in the drowned car Batman decides the
best course of action is to treat her
like the producers of this movie treat
the audience then as the Aussie Hugh
Jackman Mel Gibson Crocodile Dundee did
the Hartness the problem was doing a
comic book movie where the general
public only knows like one of your major
characters is that you end up wasting
the first third of your film doing
stupid introduction montages oh they
dragged Tom Hardy into this didn't they
no wait they hired Wray Courtney into
this didn't they the flash shows up to
thwart this one burglar I'm sure there
was a better use of his time and I have
no idea how he knew this place was being
wrong but franchise got a franchise you
know movie contains approximately 32
gratuitous shots of steak eating this is
but one of the least constant close-ups
of eating or symptomatic of a fetish at
this point archaeologist dr. June June
moon June moon what a merry Glary or
Pam's a more loosey-goosey she opened
something she shouldn't have something
evil that like parallax had been buried
slightly in the earth but not really all
that hidden so as to keep anyone from
ever finding it also is everyone with a
PhD in this movie unprofessional we've
got psychologist Harley Quinn falling in
love with the Joker of all people and
now we have dr. June moon deciding to
crack open a statue she finds during
some sort of solo archaeological dig
also this which character is almost
exactly the same thing as apocalypse in
the x-men movie that came out this year
some say the witch has a secret buried
heart whoever finds it can control the
winch which she conveniently left behind
after being released from her statue for
some reason also this whole thing brings
up more questions than it answers wait
how did you
first run into enchantress what was she
doing that alerted you to her presence
and if so how did she not already take
over the world with her powers yet how
did you know she came from this remote
jungle since dr. moon explored this cave
by herself every character in this movie
has a backstory let's see Ben on what
they were doing at the time they were
caught on this one we have to take it on
blind faith you want to put our national
security in the hands of witches
gangbangers and crocodiles this guy
would be excellent at cinemasins kind of
red flag it's almost 20 minutes and
still introducing characters I assigned
him to watch dr. moon and just as I
hoped it got personal I left everything
to trancey and it worked brilliantly
I had the witch's heart and dr. moon has
his now he'll follow my orders as Holy
Writ yeah so that's how you got him to
follow you orders but that doesn't mean
you can get all these other people to
follow them are you gonna find a few
more love witches to control Deadshot
Diablo and Jai Courtney flying men and
monsters this is the only way to protect
our country I have heard your proposal
and it still sounds pretty stupid to me
let's get a whole bunch of untrustworthy
people some of what you have minor
powers and others who simply have
tremendous human skill to try and fight
something like Colossus sure that'll
work
also patently false you've already seen
the Batman bring in like half these
metahuman villains anyway right and
Superman still exists pretend dead as he
may be for now the only way the only way
in case she confused it for the Pentagon
Cleveland what if Superman had decided
to fly down rip off the roof of the
White House who would have stopped him a
bunch of psychotic supervillains turned
government heroes of course I want to
build a team of some very bad people who
I think can do some good nope the end
the next war will be fought with these
metahumans some of these villains aren't
metahumans though right
am I missing something got a guy on this
team who robbed banks and two guys who
are good with weapons then there's a guy
who can set fires with his hands but
that only makes him marginally better
than a nine-year-old drew Barrymore you
know we can't control these people
Amanda will now demonstrate how she can
control this one person who was
possessed by a witch and translate that
into controlling everybody as we see dr.
moon turned into enchantress I will once
again ask how she was possessed by this
witch in the first place but was able to
control it enough to get back to the
States blab about it and be compromised
enchantress has the power to instantly
teleport to Iran and steal plans from a
vault but not to steal her heart back so
that Amanda can controller and sure
later they show the case has some sort
of sensor on it but that seems to be
where the case is closed and otherwise
unguarded not that this should matter to
a witch you can transport in
didn't lead to wherever she wants I
moved to authorize Manoir to establish
Task Force X maybe just the witch well
we really need is the witch I think Oh
burrito Daniel that's triple racist
movie repeats itself down to the stupid
close up up Diablo they showed just
before the wide shot of all his
destruction they say you never missed a
shot
prove it because whoever they are I
definitely don't trust them Deadshot is
definitely awesome shooting and no one
should doubt he'd be great in a gun
battle but are you telling me there's
nobody on this earth who isn't a
criminal who can get at least close to
what he's doing here psychotic
antisocial freaks it makes no sense Rick
Flagg would also be excellent at cinema
since this movie is full of people who
should be working for us without you
minding her your lady friend stays here
strapped to a board and a drug-induced
coma this movie literally has no good
guys while I do believe Joker is OCD
enough to create this circle of knives
this is clearly a case of someone
thought of a cool looking shot so they
put it in the movie even if it didn't
make sense this is worse than V for
Vendetta dominoes in the previous scene
Joker's henchmen only knew that people
were being taken to a black site and
that's only new to finding the main guy
who guards there in compromising it
Patriot Suites Hotel is totally holy God
lightning over the Washington Monument
is lightning hogging the bed I can hear
the director on set okay walk to the
window look out pensively now nosh on
the chicken leg like at your last meal
and cut perfect rick flagg is calling
but her phone is on silent for some
reason even though she's worried enough
to keep her gun nearby Amanda brings
Enchantress's brother statue with her
wherever she goes appearantly
[Music]
waitwhat since they worship something
that something has to destroy them
couldn't she destroy the world in a
million other ways that aren't nearly as
fallible I still don't know how this
witch possession works these subway cars
are being incinerated yet random people
are running past all this on the subway
platform without being affected by it
whatsoever
the first non-human entity ever attacks
Midway City and instead of calling
Batman who we apparently hate because
he's a vigilante we call The Suicide
Squad entirely made up of law-breaking
dick holes makes sense also this is
exactly what we created task force x4 to
protect us against the which we put on
Task Force X Joker found the facility
where they make the nanite explosives
that are shunned by the suicide squads
NEX also he can save his girlfriend it
got that information from Griggs the
sleazy security guard at the prison
facility but how the fuck could he know
where they made that that's like asking
an employee McDonald's worth the cattle
for these burgers raised and then I'm
telling you the exact ranch where their
captain a few things he sure they broke
into the lab but why would they be able
to hack into the government stuff just
because they did that and wouldn't the
slab which is a company owned by Wayne
Enterprises report they got robbed or
Batman would find out that got robbed
and he'd tell the government about the
security breach so having Enchantress's
heart really doesn't mean when her
brother can just do this right we won't
define how much power that is or if you
sharing it makes you any weaker but just
roll with it
and lo the unexplained goddess did
thusly begin her equally unexplained
plan to build an unexplained machine to
wipe out someone and lo and such I saw
this movie before it was called Man of
Steel and independent state 2 with a
sprinkle of Spider Man 2 I saw it at the
Museum but modern both were sending in
the fire guy the crocodile guy the crazy
chick and the guy who shoots lots of
bullets we're pretty sure this will work
somehow what on earth would make you
think that this event happened a few
minutes ago and everything you've tried
so far has been hilariously inept the
voices
is that what they really said the voice
is really said to a band in the Brooklyn
accent she'd previously had for a few
scenes military dude uses a knife to cut
open the sack when there's a perfectly
good zipper right there let them slip
not a man can climb anything is
literally all the character development
this movie will give this asshole before
killing him suddenly but even if that
hadn't been the case I descend the fact
that the great climber guy was named
like he's an uncapable prisoner what the
climbing walls and slipping knots have
to do with one another also I got a guy
who can climb that's his power
Superman eat your heart out you're next
Jackson you got its a nanite explosive
it seems to me that Amanda could have
simply told the powers-that-be that she
would stick a nanite explosive in their
necks to control this task force rather
than going with the I've got
Enchantress's heart so their method of
convincing the government about her
power if they didn't understand the
nanite explosive thing she could have
simply said I'm basically ripping off
Escape from New York and that would have
been the end of it barely John Williams
was unavailable to score this movie so
instead they led a 10th grader that was
high on mushrooms randomly picked the
soundtrack well we some kind of Suicide
Squad this is the most roll credits in
roll credits that has ever credits to
delay this last-minute chick gets a
rushed flashback backstory and movie
thinks I'm gonna give a shit about her
and movie is wrong this is good of
course that's her name
any relation to the Mortal Kombat katana
her sword sounds like we should have
recruited her for this task force rather
than a bunch of criminals it's great the
Joker is coming for but where did she
hide this phone during this and how the
hell did Flag allow these prisoners
soldiers to go on search between the
prison and the start of their mission
that's bad soldiering right there it
tells you relax this is only the third
least believable survivable helicopter
crash in this movie slipknot introduced
a mere eight minutes ago is already dead
luli offers a new entry into the most
useless and forgettable villains for the
good guys to mow down contest instantly
challenging the Kree from the Avengers
and the zombies from I am Legend these
faceless creatures are dragging flags
somewhere instead of just killing him
because they know they need to give
Deadshot or somebody time to save him no
doubt Deadshot is badass but I don't see
why a bunch of trained soldiers can't do
this very same thing
he's random monsters that just appeared
out of nowhere and have never been
explained in the movie are proof they
need Deadshot but I'm not buying it she
kisses him and he becomes a black bubbly
soldier my question is did she kiss
every one of the dozens of black bubble
heads we just saw Deadshot kill in the
previous scene cuz that's a la kissing
these mannequins perfectly represent the
relationship I have with my daughter
Joker texts without internal punctuation
and is basically my aunt tilly out of
this alien dickhead no Harley was in the
elevator then jumped down into the
elevator with her to fight he realized
this thing would have to manually open
an elevator door to access one of the
work panels to get into the elevator
shaft right so these were just stored in
the ceiling okay I'm sorry I'm always
thinking of the process by which they
turned these guys evil then pulled out a
bunch of ladders told them to go through
the ceiling tiles and told them the we
for the Suicide Squad to show up then
like always movies aren't concerned with
your perspective of this battle they all
know you like loud noises and the
illusion of something exciting and
that's what they call an action scene
these days this asshole does nothing for
most of the Second Battle in a row man
yes I know he eventually saves the day
but is there nothing he can offer
between zero and saves the day this guy
apparently needs to be goaded into using
his powers now he realized why Diablo
was conscientiously objecting to using
his powers it didn't have anything to do
with killing his girlfriend that's
because he's one of the most powerful
characters in this movie and he could
have made the last 15 minutes go by in
five does chemically altering your
appearance require this mega dye from
super high up in a building I'll take
scenes we only included because we hired
an a-lister to play Joker and felt
obligated for 800 Alex seriously
everybody is gone after that flashback
except for Deadshot who has been the
leader of this thing for the entire
mission you did flag or somebody would
be concerned about them not being with
the group but you'd be wrong so the
mission was to save Amanda all along and
I guess enchantress and her army here
because she needs them to get her heart
but I don't really know why it feels
like she could have zipped in and out of
this place herself if she wanted to even
if she was building some sort of machine
and I'm not sure how her army would have
been able to find a secret stairway and
punch the secret code to access this
room anyway and I guess Amanda didn't
tell them they were coming to save her
because of something something proved
their loyalty this movie doesn't lay
clear any of the motivations for the
characters so we have to take stabs what
the plot is about she takes an average
person and she turns them into a soldier
who can take a headshot and still fight
not really they're pretty awful army
wise they might do well at one of those
haunted houses where the employees can
touch you though
what the these people all knowingly
worked for a clandestine agency and
presumably had some level of clearance
or basic trust there is no reason to
shoot them all over this hell you got
permission from your bosses to run this
suicide squad right that is just a mean
lady yeah movie this is the time for
one-liner jokes just after the
unnecessary murder of several innocents
murder then one-liner that's the comedy
formula lead forth by Jerry Lewis I
think first eject it's not important for
you to know how the Joker hijacked this
military helicopter just know that he
did and be content that he's Joker and
can do anything not a joke earnest men
ensure they don't hit any good guys by
firing this way even if Joker did all
these things to save Harley what a
terrible plan this is she could easily
be killed of course that might not be a
consideration for him but considering
everything he's done so far it's
ridiculous he didn't wait for a better
opportunity the military bombs the out
of this helicopter and they all survived
and god dammit I have to put up with to
make sense videos and then Harley
survives this fall Jesus Christ I've
started to think the safest location in
this movie is in a crashing helicopter
why even have a helicopter crash if
everybody's gonna survive all of them
this movie is a series of helicopter
crashes and people eating large pieces
of meat also you survive a helicopter
crash and you survive a helicopter crash
and after watching what she thinks his
Joker dying in a chopper crash Harley
understandably goes down to street level
and pounced on the roof of a car in the
rain because that's just what you do in
these situations
okay Harley has had her bomb
disconnected is presumed dead and could
go wherever the she wants why is she
sticking around to eventually go back to
torture prison is my heart returned I
can finish my weapon
yeah because before you couldn't get
that done for some reason you the
feeling someone on the set was like
isn't she super powerful why hasn't she
finished her weapon if she clearly has
the power to do it and then somebody
said let's make it seem like she needed
her heart all along to do it and that'll
shut him the fuck up when does this end
flak character inside the movie says out
loud what everyone watching it is
thinking what we almost pulled it off no
you didn't he killed a bunch of bubbly
monsters and briefly rescued a
psychopath that is going to put you
right back in prison
that's not pulling at all that's
participating in a LARP and put the
battery phone I'm taking my kids to
Mom's thought I married a nice man with
demon tattoos all over his head face in
75% of his body yes this guy's back
stories that he got mad at his wife for
scolding him for criminal activity and
then he burned his family that's the
back story and this character deserves
no second chances even though the movie
gives him one
wasn't she already free of the nanite
explosives anyway you're not a write to
you every day and I hand selected seven
of those daily letters to include in
this small bundle also emotional moment
yes but flag was traveling and doing
combat this whole movie with these
letters stuffed in his chest just in
case my daughter is gonna note it hurt
daddy it's not a piece of except for all
those people I killed for money I can't
take that back but killing a which gets
me points though Captain Boomerang there
was a boomerang which apparently it
doesn't boomerang at all but flies like
a drone into Enchantress's lair and has
a camera on it that broadcast through
his phone as a flooded tunnel leads
right underneath that building because
Killer Croc has been worthless up at
this point so there's a flooded tunnel
now so his character could actually do
something killed her husband use that
sword
yeah but who the fuck cares man you
don't fight with us what if I lose
control are we still debating about this
did Diablo do something good earlier
shouldn't he be over this by now I mean
not the killing his wife gets part but
the using fire for good part so that's
your old lady huh well you need to
handle this I get up there smack on our
ass tell her knocked it off this movie
is so aggressively misogynistic but it
briefly hosted Access Hollywood
I've been waiting thank you alright
didn't chantry's just now realize the
Suicide Squad was here
what exactly are her detecting powers
did this take some time or was she just
letting them think they were Hardy and I
know what you want loopy will now waste
time showing us what a few characters
really want and won't pay any attention
to what I want which is for the movie to
end this dude suddenly has horrible aim
with his tentacle things after wiping
out most of the human race he interacted
with before this also why did a chant
respond with all that what everybody
really wants bulls and not just send
this guy in behind them to destroy them
in the first place there is no way
you've bonded to these assholes in a few
days time and have to consider them
family UJ Hernandez's character whose
name I forgot let me show you what I
really am
nor would it have been nice to know this
character could Voltron into a super
tall fire gone before now yes yes it
would but that would have spoiled the X
Malcolm I'll be honest Killer Croc is
underwater fighting bad guys I've
forgotten why or who or how but I
understand Killer Croc to be a water
based bad guy and therefore I accept the
existence of this scene even as I sin
it's forgettable Ness this fight would
really be interesting if we had any clue
about their powers or the stakes or the
rules or anything resembling a plot my
took you long enough you got your heart
back a couple of hours ago
feels like the stupid machine should be
killing fools by now well there goes HBO
again it's a secret facility Oh fight
against all-powerful which devolves into
hand-to-hand combat because of course it
does
damn I thought we were gonna run out of
time but then we managed to find one
more way to have a dude punch a woman in
the face
oh look Killer Croc finally made it to
the battle after so many minutes of
whatever that's been doing that is
indeed of a Jenica and I'd be just as
offended as a moviegoer of hardly was a
dude and this was a kick to the balls
actually this movie is basically a kick
in the balls and a Rob Schneider cameo
away from being an Adam Sandler movie
and yeah she could have done this like
five minutes ago right that enchantress
can't tell Harley as bullshit and
doesn't notice the sword right next to
it hey here's something to do after the
entire movie of you being worthless
thanks for being nearby this entire
scene is done in slow motion for a
whopping 90 seconds so that the agony
can be greater during watching it oh and
all this chick was pretty worthless
during this movie name one thing she did
you know one person who could end this
mess right now
Harley whose neck thing doesn't work
anymore but did this movie forget about
that I guess it did or Harley just
doesn't want to help or something in
this one movie alone that Joker has been
a red herring a MacGuffin and an ex
machina
this is crown jewels hey mr. Wayne end
credits sequence is so much like the
Nick Fury Avengers bullshit that you
might as well copy and paste the Marvel
into this DC product
you can do it the matrix is telling my
brain that it is juicy and delicious
ignorance is bliss whoa did I fight you
didn't mean to